caleb smith three and seven for the 461
era he's in his fifth season in the big
leagues second with the diamondbacks a
three pitch mix fastball slider change
up mookie bets comes off the injured
list not only leading it off but playing
at second base today smith threw his
wine here he comes and ball four lead
off walk here's chris taylor now he's
had a good series he's had a great
season he's an all-star one and two and
this pitch from smith and a swinging
strike three two on four seeker in this
opening inning runners go and the pitch
and he struck him out swinging on the
ball that was up
and somehow someway
caleb smith survives the first inning a
lot of pitches but he strands two a
couple of walks
julio arias to the mound and the bottom
of the first
julio orios on the mound the 24 year old
left-hander 12-3 with a 354 era looking
to get to 13 wins on the season i'd be
tied for most in the major leagues
who's back of the lineup
here's a pitch and that slide and that's
a base hit welcome back to tell into
right center field
he lied that ball out there and he's on
base with one out here
martay aboard for drew ellis came off of
the bench in his major league debut
friday night
on the hands a flare into left center
field then milky tracks down turns and
heaves back to first
first start at second base this season
just his second since he was a rookie
now ben's the hitter you know what he
can do he walked to lead off today's
ball game
and the o2 to bench and a swing and a
miss he struck him out for round number
two in the inning taylor at the plate
struck out his first time some of the
best sliders that
caleb smith's thrown over these two
innings were to taylor to finish him off
another 3-2 coming to chris taylor
it was only a matter of time another
free pass and they'll finally get a run
fifth walk in the first two innings
pollock steps on home taylor gets an rbi
and it's one nothing
but turner coming up
run against caleb smith a few weeks ago
one of his seven in july
the o2
line drive
and it gets under the glove of ahmed
throw to first not in time dodgers lead
to nothing
albert walked his first time to the
plate today and the first inning was
stranded
the 10th pitch
to albert pujols
is rifled down the line it's a fair ball
pool
will unload the bases
the dodgers get five here in the second
a slow drip and then it rips open
peacock comes on to try and get the
third out and he'll face corey singer
the left-handed hitter
bounce to second for hager
on to first to walker and the inning
mercifully comes to an end after nine go
to the plate for los angeles they get
five they get three hits
and
they leave a runner we head to the
bottom of the second
one gone for jake hager who's set to
make his
arizona debut
fastballs by him
first k one or two gone 95 with some
late life
holidays gone five for his first 20.
three infielders on the left including
mookie betts close to second base pitch
to holiday he waves and misses he goes
down on strikes
julio's faced eight men giving up two
hits in the game so far
and neither of them have gotten past
first base so we'll go to the third
dodgers five arizona nothing pitcher
urias
who does have nine hits and eight rbi
eyes on the gear here's a two-two pitch
to arias and a ground ball back toward
the middle diving played by henry gets
up and he throws him out at first hager
took the head away from maria's to end
the ending and save a run with that
runner at third base
side retired the dodgers are hitting the
inning and they'll leave that man we'll
head to the bottom of the third three
four and five here for arizona drew
ellis leading off eighth pitch coming to
drew ellis
first weekend in the big leagues he's
down swinging on the elevated fastball
one away so man in second with one away
for josh reddick
2-2
reddick waves and misses he's out on
strikes two down
fourth strikeout for julio hager with
two down and walker at second base
and the pitch on the outside corner the
breaking ball through the back door
caught the right hand and hitting hager
looking
three strikeouts in the inning one hit
one left one error we'll go to the fifth
it's the dodgers five arizona nothing
at the corners runaway billy mckinney
that's through base hit mckinney to
bring home the dodgers sixth run of the
day
rbi soon gonna score corey seeger six
nothing in the fifth
back to the top of the order mookie
betts sold for two with a walk in his
first game back
that gets by
and brings in another one
touchdown and an extra point dodgers
ahead of the diamondbacks
barnes in to score mckinney to third
invited two here in the fifth
the pitch bet swings
skies it to center marte going back he
got a beat on it
and shy of the warning track makes the
catch
two on the other dodgers get a pair
though
they up their lead they leave one we
head to the bottom of the fifth in
phoenix
car show's second inning single extended
is on bay street 12. lurias watches
everything kershaw does
fast spot to the outside corner to get
varchow looking
sixth k for urias and
brian holliday the catcher maria is
ready for an o2 to holiday
he got him to chase
a couple k's to open the fifth
two on two out for pollock
down the line fair ball another base hit
for aj pollock
third of the day for him and it'll drive
in two
it's nine nothing
actually drives in just one seeger
stopped at third so it's eight nothing
either way third knock of the day for aj
pollock
austin barnes the batter now
barnes the hitter
he's been on twice today with a walk in
a single scored two and he lines this
one that's caught by walker
that would have been a hit had walker
not been positioned perfectly there two
on the ending way off the back the
dodgers though get a run they do so on
one hitting the i think two head batters
and two men left on base
two on two out in the hitters turner
just one of those hits back in the
second knocked in a room with a single
it's a fly ball to left field towards
the pole
it is gone three-run shot justin turner
almost an instant replay of the two-run
blast last night that high drive down
behind his 20th of the year
that kind of stretch for aj pollock huh
three hits today rbi double his last
time
he's got a hit in an 11
and 11 in a row he's reached in 20 in a
row he's hitting 440
during that 20 game on bay streak
slide to center field
a four hit dave for aj pollock
all the way to the wall seegers headed
home pollock's got an rbi double it's 12
nothing
two singles two doubles two rbis for aj
[ __ ]
now is beatty pinch hitting banning for
price i bet your price lobbied for an
at-bat
didn't get it did and hagar and ahmed
and it's
caught by ahmed or caught by hager to
end the ending that was actually hager's
ball all the way and nick wanted to
catch it and ran into him but hager
holds on
and the inning comes to an end that ball
is right at hager
12 nothing game and a position player
pitching brian holiday
cookie bets to lead it off
uh
uh-oh
down the line
off the pole home run
whatever it was it got turned around and
it made it 13-0 mookie's got a home run
in his first game back
they all count
christian walker the diamondbacks first
baseman
he went around and that does it
jeffrey ramirez and his dodger debut
pitches the final two innings and
plenty else to talk about in this 13-0
win